[Music]
sir he was
dreaming he was half a
magician so we took him with us
all that beauty the vases the gold Everything
left there for a world that we didn't
even know if
there was the world of
souls I'm looking for Mrs. Flora the  I said I would be
Look look who's here my only
friend Italy Thanks
eat six If you want I can give you a
crash course in
[Music]
[Applause] [
Music]
Italian we'll keep an
eye on them [Music] [
Music]
Spell
stealing things  of the souls there
[Music]
I curse don't lose heart You
always find everything
[Applause]
eh
But what have you done here You yes S [
Music]
bad now we'll show you
things that not even archaeologists dream of
[Music]
n